各位同学
今天分享的课程内容是创作生涯里的小故事
听起来是不是很轻松
没有什么负担好
那我们继续分享下去了
首先我们一如惯例
先来分享一首韵脚诗
这首韵脚词叫宿命
烟味如铁线般死命的纠缠
黄昏对你的熟悉
被慢慢慢慢磨成一把锋利的刀刃
我用来火开横切面的青春
开始寻找与你相遇的年份
在最最外圈的年轮
我却只看到紧紧相依的你们
原来在这一生
我只能是你其中一圈的认真
各位同学记得诗的语义结构
你要去呼应前面铺陈的线索
因为我前面写我用来剖开横切面的青春
然后后面直接在最最外圈的年轮
就是竖锯开之后的年轮嘛
我只能是你其中一圈的认真
就是这个人
可能不是对方的真命天子或真命天女
接下来要分享的小故事
我们就从青花瓷这首歌开始上几堂课
有分享过青花瓷
原来的歌名不叫青花瓷
一开始叫青铜器
后来汝窑最后才定案为青花瓷
这是创作以前的故事
还有一段创作以后的故事
当这首歌写完之后呢
我就很开心
因为那个是所谓中国风的创作
是前山坡的主打
那我就跟公司的企划讲
因为企划要发新闻稿
他要理解说创作的缘由啊
过程我就跟他讲歌的名字
然后呢他就没有反应
你知道吗
我就觉得很奇怪
这个这不是很好的一个一个idea吗
他怎么没有很欣喜或干嘛
然后在电话中也没有太多的一些表示
后来我才知道说哦
原来他把青花瓷听成青花瓷
他想说天哪
怎么他又想说怎么办
这信用卡怎么发
因为公司的员工撰写新闻稿的同人
他肯记忆某种程度的尊重创作
他不好意思过问
你知道吗
他想说
青花瓷会不会
我用青蛙一跳一跳去象征爱情的过程
然后进化不通
跳下水去象征爱情的结束
所以他觉得可能我赋予它的寓意
结果不是他只是听错而已
叫青花瓷
接下来分享一个小故事
是兰亭序
兰亭序
这首歌是我所有创作过的歌词中
最多时空最多场合写的歌
怎么讲
那时候我刚好出差去内地
然后周同学要录音的
我出发前根本就没有写好
然后就又不想让他担心
我都传讯息都快好了快好了
什么胜负歌根本就a one就还没有写好
我在飞机上写一段
然后落地的时候就传一段给他
然后进了活动的现场
然后在摄影棚的休息室又写
然后写完之后他就说哦
他下午先唱哪一段
回到酒店的时候又写
然后酒店休息的时候上厕所也在想
吃饭的时候也在想
这首歌很特别
分别在六个嫦娥接力赛的把它完成
一个是飞机上
一个是活动场地的摄影棚
再来就是酒店
还有厕所
上厕所时候我也在想
还有休息室
就是饭厅六个场合接力赛
所以这首歌我也印象很深刻
接下来分享的是我首次发表的歌
我首次发表的歌
相信有些人知道就是一首闽南语歌
叫苟活虾
落雨声
是我们台湾那个闽南语天后江蕙姐所唱的
那这一首歌都要讲意义非凡
为什么呢
因为是第一首发表的
但其实呢我第一首发表的词却不是这首
怎么说呢
我第一首发表的词就七个字而已
就说发表罗和香落雨声是完整的作品
歌词作品
但是第一次发表的文字作品只有七个字
你说宪哥有签下一个团体叫休比杜华
那修比杜海里面有首歌叫野孩子
那野孩子的这首歌的作词者
其实是用团体去署名的
就是丘比杜华
那大家当初在集思广益的时候呢
我也参与了
在里面我贡献了一句话
就是我行我素
不伪装
我想我是不是不违章
这七个字哦
是我创作生涯里面身为词人的作品里面
其实第一次第一个发表的所有作品
就是那七个字
但名字里面没有
我就觉得很微妙
这种过程历历在目
然后接下来再分享刚刚的落雨声
当初写好的时候经历了很多的过程
一开始江慧娴
那时候的第一位是闽南语歌手的天后级
然后我跟周小雪很兴奋
然后他谱曲
我填词
然后他把vocal唱进去
我就很开心哦
我就赶快骑摩托车送到对方的唱片公司
我还记得叫大型唱片
然后送的时候我就回来了
然后回来的时候再等等消息
等了半天
一个礼拜过去的
两个礼拜快过去了
诶电话响了
然后他们唱片公司的人打来
就说诶你们有个demo带呃
叫我虾
我们还蛮喜欢的啊
这首歌我们应该是会用哦
我是接电话的那个人
因为我是版权部嘛
负责采取的一个授权
我就很好好很好啊
就可以啊
授权没问题
然后对方迟疑了一下
他就说那我们可不可以只买曲不买词词
就是我写的
我家电话中呃
停顿了几秒呃
呃当然是可以啊
呃没问题
然后心在滴血
以为小说天后将会要唱我写的歌了
结果呢他不要我写的词
我就觉得啊好挫折
做营销费证他又下来了
可是呢隔了一个礼拜
他们又打电话来了
就说哎不好意思
那首歌我们鸽子也会一起买哦
天哪心情喜上温暖
后来我才知道说作为一个新人
你没有获得任何的奖项或肯定
或一种所谓的历练
你在上面却没有履历
那人家觉得用你的作品基本上没有广告效应
就是什么金牌作词人
他你没有这种身份
里面有这种身份没有加到分
而且歌词是可以被替换的
他音乐旋律一旦确定之后
他重新入狱重新填词嘛
我在想他们可能重新找人写
或许没有写我写的那么的贴切
或所谓的契合度吧
他们就放弃了
就回来重新用我写的词
然后这首歌发表的时候是搭配台湾一个电视剧
叫春天北慕星
这是一个方言的连续剧
叫春天父母心
你知道吗
我在电视荧幕上
因为通常电视剧演完之后
电视主题曲会出来吗
片尾曲才会上字幕
我在电视荧幕上看到我的名字在上面
我就觉得啊值得了
纵使签约之后一年没有任何作品发表
纵使每天骑摩托车来上班
骑了快一年
最后才贷款买车
而且那个贷款还是跟周同学借的钱
就是借了大概人民币5万投七款
就是这些都无关紧要的
我的名字出现在电视机里面的就是作词者
就上面就有我的名字
就觉得一切就值得了
这过程中就是点滴在心头
然后再来比较有印象的歌是娘子
那是我跟周同学第一次合作所谓中国风的创作
但是娘子这首歌的曲风完全没有中国风的影子
就是因为这样反差很大
市场的回响让我们有点惊讶哦
这样子一个很西方的一个节奏
居然填上了仿宋词的歌词作品
而且那时候基本上不太会有人这么做
以前传统的所谓中国风概念跟方向的创作
他就是词跟曲都在一个范畴里面
而不会说旋律的节奏很快
带点RV带点快节奏
但是呢你的歌词却是仿宋词的一个文字底蕴
这种落差反而造成了这首歌的精彩度
所以这首歌我也印象很深刻
而且呢这首歌我当初填了两个版本的歌词
一个就是四平八稳的情歌
一个就是娘子
因为当时我在想说我舔娘子
万一周同学说娘子娘子我还相公呢
因为这个词汇当歌迷很奇怪诶
没想到周同学的频率跟我是一样的
他反而喜欢娘子这首歌词
而不喜欢一般所以比较安全的情歌歌词
那我就觉得我就放心了
而且公司的总经理荣哥也觉得很好
这样子的搭配有一个创作上的一种视野跟角度
也因此呢娘子这首歌就是所谓我跟周同学
中国风的创作系列里面第一首歌
而且当初没有人叫我这么做
是因为我觉得说你要留在这个圈子
一定要有一个不一样诠释歌曲的一个角度
纵使它只是歌词文字
你要先说出一个不一样的故事
也因此娘子这首歌呢
就奠定了我们在中国风创作
这个系列的一个里程碑
接下来分享的这个小故事是上海
当初创作的时候
我找了好多资料
就砸到最后我都很迫不及待想去上海
就是隔了好几年后才因为出差的关系
去了上海这个城市
它的结构
它的城市的色块
建筑的样貌或者城市的表情
就跟我想象的差不多
因为他城市的面貌很丰富
可能有徐汇区有洋楼
然后有外滩
有十里洋场
有弄堂
然后有石库门
现代的建筑
就是觉得哇城市的表情很丰富
那这首歌当初创作的时候耗尽了脑汁
而且版本也是不止一个
只是说那些版本不完整
不像娘子
娘子
是我完完整整的写了两个歌词的版本
但是上海1943我是一直替换消失的旧时光
1943还是消失的旧时光
我的悲伤我就想来想去啊
干脆用年代把这首歌定调
因为1943有点想象空间
而且很多影视作品都会描绘十里洋场
外滩十里洋场
当初就上海的一个风貌跟故事
后来就决定了
用1943这个词汇当歌词的一个主轴
就开始酝酿所有歌词的内容
后来好多年后再一次去到了上海
就觉得真的是跟我想象中的几乎一模一样
因为我收集了很多旧上海的资料
虽然上海市其实有很时尚很摩登的都会区
但是他有一些旧城区他还是保留着
所以那时候就觉得诶
跟我想象中收集资料的内容很契合
这首歌也是让我印象很深刻的一首歌
接下来要分享一个创作的小故事
是令我心惊胆跳的故事
那时候宪哥签下一个闽南语歌手叫王开成
他的专辑有个特色
就是说它的旋律基本上都是翻译歌
大多数是来自于日本
可能像桑田佳佑
玉知浩二跟圣元敬之这些名字我都还记得
为什么我就是处理版权那个人心惊胆跳
怎么心惊胆跳
他们把这些人的旋律填上闽南语歌词
但是不是我填的
那时候我在我还刚进来
大家可能连自己公司的人都不用我的词好
没关系
然后呢重点是他已经唱好了
印刷好了
因为此曲的授权有个OPSP
那OP是原来的版权
我们连他们版权公司的名字都印好了
印在CD的内页里面的
你知道多紧张吗
因为日本人做事很谨慎
他要求我们把这个闽南语歌翻成英文传给他看
他看内容
他说看有没有诋毁原作的精神
会有什么不雅的一些内容
所有的翻译要时间翻译好之后传承过去
也要时间
然后他们的决策可能没那么快
那个时候我几乎快跳楼
为什么那时候的卡带已经印好了
西帝内业的OP已经是他们公司的
但是他们还没有同意
还没有授权
因为他们在审核我们翻译好的英文歌词
他们看不懂闽南语吗
你给他中文也没有用
他审英文歌词
天呐我想说他万一不授权
那这些CD卡带赔偿的钱我要赔吗
因为我是版权嘛
我是负责处理的人嘛
我那时候不想怎么办
那时我们公司在基隆路
在11楼
我就一直看着窗外
我想说这11楼有多高啊
然后就一直盯着那个传真机
那个年代合约的授权
基本上就是依赖传真机
他就对方签完名之后传过来
我一直在等传真机的声音响起来
等不到
等了三天
基本上卡带已经印好了
在仓库了
差不多要发货了
宪哥都不晓得
我根本还没有取得对方的授权
因为我不会处理
我又不是做版权的料
我不想说那个步骤
我还托人去翻译
然后干嘛处理一大堆事情
我那时候就是乡下来的小孩
那你叫我直接去跟日本接洽
这个版权我哪里懂啊
虽然后来我熬过来了
虽然我后来也没有跳
就是很紧张
后来终于那个传真机声音响了
我跑过去看
吃吃吃吃吃吃吃吃
我看到了授权
OK同意答应了
我没有跟全公司任何人讲
我怎么能讲呢
我就一直很穷
紧张紧张了三天三夜
一直从窗户往外看
天哪
这种事情不能再发生了
这是小故事中的大灾难
接下来就是卡带
我们刚进公司的时候
我跟杰伦那时候还有卡带
而且我们录音的demo带就是卡带
我记得很清楚
有5分钟的卡带跟10分钟
然后是白色的
因为方便你写歌的名字嘛
那时候呢录好了
我跟杰伦很兴冲冲
哪里有妖哥的讯息
我们就开始唱
开始录
录完了我去送demo带
骑摩托车去送DM带
后来我们公司的会计很神奇
他觉得说我就是接版权的
版权应该我处理
怎么能叫快递呢
快递要另外花钱呢
我不觉得这逻辑怎么来的
就是他处理的态度很特别
就是我们公司也有经济部
然后只要这个艺人去
不管是有什么通告
然后随身的宣传一起去的时候
下戏的时候吃东西
吃东西的钱
他觉得这个宣传这个助理要自己出
他的想法是说
你今天就算不随这个艺人出击去外景
你也要吃饭啊
那你每天固定要吃饭呢
那今天只不过刚好工作中
你在这个外景里面
那公司等自己买便当
那为什么你的钱要公司出
就很奇怪的逻辑哦
当然最后他还是照一般唱片圈或影视圈里面的
那种不成文的规定
就是这本来就是公司出的便当啊
怎么能说这个人没有出差的时候
在公司叫便当
是自己出钱
然后等到出差跟这个艺人出去的时候
这个便当也要踏出
就很奇怪嘛
然后我就是这样子啊
我就没有去抗争好吧
那我就自己骑摩托
有请我自己出
就是公司推歌的demo带我自己送
然后有钱我自己出停车费罚单我自己出
那个是我们会计小姐
我们的宪哥大人完全不知情
我们宪哥是很大气的
他看到的是大笔的支出哦
宣传费多少
资助费多少
然后制作费里面有一个快递费
是可能是20块人民币
他是看不出来的
但是我那时候没有想那么多
我觉得我觉得也也还好
因为我喜欢这份工作
然后那个卡带就是我们录好之后就赶快送过去
后来卡带消失了
周同学的专辑第二张范特西还有卡带
第三章以后就没有卡带了
进入了CD光碟的年代
最后再跟同学们分享一个也是心惊胆跳
但是夹杂着哭笑不得的一个小故事
那时候呢
对方给我们的demo带是透过email从电脑接收的
然后有一次印象很深刻
一个香港歌手
然后打电话来就说诶我们那首歌已经开始呃
填词了吗
已经开始写了吗
然后我接的嘛
我是版权部负责哦
开始了那个歌还蛮好听的啊
有有有进行了进行了
我就挂上去去电脑里面开始找email
找到了点那个附加档
一点开他既空白的来
我都已经说很好听了
我不晓得怎么办
他寄了两个党
一个是文字党
就创作的方向跟建议跟关键字
一个是影音党
我在想他可能没有记好
反正就是空白的
可是我已经跟他讲说很好听的
那我不晓得怎么办
我想了半天
琢磨了两天
我想说好吧
那就跟他讲说哦
我电脑坏掉了
因为有故障
你可不可以再记一次
那对方也没想那么多
哦哈哈没问题
那就再记一次就化解了危机
后来呢只要是email的demo带我一定点开
纵使我不会第一时间去写
同学们记得
这个是进入这个圈子之后的一个习惯
而且一定要好好的养成这个好习
李冠好
那今天分享的这些小故事
都是创作过程中的点点滴滴
也是我个人的记忆
风景创作上的一些回忆
分享给大家